denn wollen die geschichte des colón ein
künstliches wesen das karriere gemacht
hat wie man gewissen sind bis heute bis
zu den modernen robotern sowie ab in
chorin wie würden sie denn den golem
sehen wollen wir dich sehn als prototyp
zu dem modernen e roboter wie sie so
schön sagen vielleicht mit einem
unterschied dass der name gott ist in
diesem roboter ist und in dem heutigen
roboter hat die religion gar nichts
damit zu tun wie mutter mensch weiß
alles wir sind ja hier sowas in der
jüdischen synagoge von frank und im
zentrum des jüdischen lebens in st
gallen als der alte tradition das
judentum ist aber auch offen für moderne
für neue gedanken für fortschritt für
technischen fortschritt so dieser spagat
moderne und tradition ist der boden gut
aufgehoben war natürlich war wie eine
religion sind wie amos oz schon uns
gelehrt hat von m buchstaben und
menschen
wir glauben nicht an menschen sondern an
buchstaben und die welt wurde auch durch
buchstaben erzeugt und das ist die thora
die wir bald sehen werden in der
bundeslade das ist die quelle des
wissens und darauf für das judentum
immer weiter entwickelt die leute diese
entwicklung geht weiter
also dieses dieser spagat von dem du
sprichst im wesen des judentums
das sind 1936 in jerusalem geboren sie
waren an vielen orten auf der welt als
rabbiner tätig heute in st gallen
sie haben ja sind richtig eingetaucht in
die jüdische tradition und sie wollten
wir noch die kurve eigentlich gerne wo
das judentum wirklich damit anfängt weil
mich interessiert ob dieser golem auch
eben in den quellen des judentums ob der
ra vorkommt er kommt in rabbinischen
quellen nicht in der ähnlichen dem fünf
bücher mose aber ob das eigentlich eine
realität
möglich nur ist nein es ist mehr eine
legende figur dass es nicht eine figur
an dem man glauben sie haben wir unsere
thorarollen mit dem fischer mosel die
ersten fünf bücher der hebräischen bibel
die auch in der marxistischen ergeben
da kommt aber nicht vor er kommt nicht
vor aber die rabbiner sehen den ersten
menschen hat sein kohlen und etap gott
geschaffen hat nicht der mensch und dann
zu einer bestimmten zeit in den zwölf
stunden in dem er lebte er war im bett
mit eva und mit war 2 und kamen vier
runter vom deb also kain und abel wohnen
geboren und erst danach fängt die
menschheit an das wort kommt in den
psalmen vor einmal in den 139 m zusammen
aber die gestalt als solche kommt erst
im talmud mehr gibt eine sehr schöne
geschichte von einem rabbiner der in
babylon war er aber und der schicht
jemanden um sein freund ein rabbiner im
land israel aguilera zu besuchen und
therapie sicher spricht mit dem und
merkt dass der nicht antwortet dass
rotkohl im kommt hier nicht vor aber es
wird darauf hingewiesen dass er merkt
dass da kein mensch ist so zornig und
bringt ihn komponiert ist die frage
hatte jemand umgebracht nein weil er
sein wollen
und eben der golem hat anfänge in der
alten traditionen der hand entwickelt
sich dort auf das button
als ein highlight das eben lernen der
thora und das der mystique mental ist es
sehr populären zwölften jahrhundert und
sind auch verschiedene zeremonien die
damit verbunden sind nur mit dem wagen
von m
vortrag da hätte erwähnt als jemand der
den menschen dient in den menschen hilft
mir wurden auch noch mein vater mit die
geschichte der zürcher goalie wasser in
am freitag bringt für die leute an dem
in braga ghetto und rabbiner hat
vergessen den namen gottes ab und des
großen interviews kommt mir wasser oder
wasser aufhört
und zum glück war ein etabliertes er
gerne lang gesungen hat und er hat noch
nicht diese zahlen gesungen wurde der
sabbat reinkommt in der synagoge und da
kommt er im letzten moment den namen
gottes von mund von dem wurm rausnehmen
damit er nicht arbeitet - arbeit und so
wurden juden gerettet ist ein
praktischer teil dieser kohlen oder
sondern rabbiner warum sie nie in der
versuchung auch mal von collins nein
nein das sind schöne gemen schöne
geschichten und den passiven wieweit
kannte menschen zu gott kommen wo ich
doch der unterschied das hängt an
unserer seele
sie sind materie wie die spielqualität
aber das theologische das ziel heftig
kommt von gott das kann ein goalie
erreichen und auch nicht an roboter
erziehung für diesen einblick in die
jüdische tradition der golem tief
verwurzelt in der jüdischen tradition
die digitale welt die vernetzte welt
erinnert sich manchmal auch an die
geschichte von gorleben
da liegen die fluch und deswegen nahe
beieinander jetzt geht es hier nämlich
mit der sternstunde philosophie weiter
und da ist mein kollege yves bost am
world forum in zürich eingetaucht in die
digitale welt